[Musik] hallo zusammen wir machen heute
puddingplunder ich finde alles was mit
Hefeteig und Vanillepudding zu tun hat schmeckt
einfach immer richtig gut ich starte direkt mit
dem Rezept ihr findet wie immer alle ganz genauen
Mengenangaben hier unten in der Infobox und ich
starte jetzt hier mit meinem Mehl ich habe hier
die volle Ladung 500 g ich werde aber nicht alles
reingeben denn wenn ihr einmal zu viel Mehl in
den Hefeteig gibt dann ist es meistens schon zu
spät daher also nachgeben kann man immer daher
so ein bisschen was zur Seite legen jetzt kommt
natürlich auch immer das Volumen der Eier
an wie viele da benötigt da gebe ich jetzt
Trockenhefe mit dazu ihr könnt auch frische Hefe
verwenden die dann in die lauwarme Milch gleich
einarbeiten falls ihr frische Hefe verwenden
würde aber Trockenhefe habe ich zum Beispiel
immer da und dann könnt ihr auch schon die nächste
trockene Zutat dazu geben das wäre dann Zucker
und ich gebe noch eine sehr sehr gute Prise Salz
mit rein einfach weil das noch mal den süßen
Geschmack ein bisschen hebt das verrühre ich jetzt
einmal kurz mit dem Schneebesen damit es sich gut
verbindet dann wird da einfach eine Mulde ich
habe einfach saubere Hände heute nehme ich nicht
die Küchenmaschine sonst mache ich das gerne da
bin ich ganz ehrlich mit euch aber ich wollte
euch einfach zeigen dass es auch mit den Händen
geht so da kommt jetzt lauwarme Milch mit rein
und Öl dann nehmt ihr einfach ein neutrales
entweder Sonnenblumen oder Rapsöl es gibt
nämlich mit dazu und wenn ich nichts für die
Eier okay die Eier gebe ich noch mit dazu dann
nehme ich aber jetzt nicht alles sondern nur das
Eiweiß das Eigelb heben wir uns auf eins für den
Vanillepudding und das andere zum bestreichen
und Eiweiß macht den Hefeteig auch noch mal so
ein bisschen fluffiger daher verwerte ich das
einfach und gibt das hier mit rein und danach
könnt ihr aber kneten [Musik] beim Hefeteig
kneten mache ich so dass ich mir zwischendrin
während ich knete einmal die Hände waschen muss
damit wieder alles auf Reset ist und ich den
Teig so ein bisschen besser fühlen kann und dann
gebe ich das ähm also jetzt auf die Arbeitsfläche
persönlich finde es dann im Anschluss so
ein bisschen einfacher als jetzt in der
weiter zu kneten und gebe dann wirklich immer nur
purple ein bisschen Mehl mit dazu denn wenn ihr zu
viel Mehl dazu gibt dann ist es einfach zu trocken
und wenn sich das sage ich immer wieder in meine
Hefeteig wie du es aber in dem Fall ist es wieder
so wenn sich euer Hefeteig wie euer Ohrläppchen
anfühlt einfach mal fühlen also es ist komplett
identisch richtig crazy äh dann ist er fertig
der darf ganz leicht also er klebt nicht mehr
so wirklich sondern ja so minimal also man hat
das Gefühl okay ganz ganz leicht vielleicht noch
aber jetzt nicht so dass da irgendwie noch mehr
fehlt oder das super super klebrig ist und ich
nehme jetzt hier noch mein backtrennspray weil
ich jetzt auch nicht zusätzlich unnötig viel Mehl
noch mal in meine Schüssel und auf den Teig geben
möchte weil ob man will oder nicht das arbeitet
sich ja auch in den Hefeteig ein so jetzt schön
luftdicht verschließen und wenn ihr Zeit habt
eine Stunde gehen lassen wenn ihr keine Zeit
habt dann 45 Minuten auch okay an einem warmen Ort
wo kein Durchzug herrscht so wir machen jetzt in
der Zwischenzeit schon mal unsere Pudding Füllung
die darf dann nämlich anschließend auch abkühlen
und zwar haben wir hier Milch habe ich jetzt nicht
alles in meinen Topf er hat es noch ausgeschaltet
ein bisschen was so um die kann ich kann so
schlecht schätzen so um die 67 Esslöffel dass
ich mir jetzt hier noch beiseite da rühre ich
jetzt Speisestärke ein das ist so ein bisschen
wie ihr kennt das doch wenn ihr auch fertigen
Vanillepuddingpulver kauft dann ist es doch
auch so dass man das Pulver erst so ein bisschen
in die Milch einrührt das hilft einfach dass sich
das später besser verbindet und ihr das nicht
zu schnell erwärmt und dann Klümpchen erhaltet
ähm das ist übrigens super super tolle Wahl
jeweils ich weiß nicht ob man sieht aber ich
versuche es jetzt und zu kleckern hier rein zu
bekommen beim Backen ist natürlich ganz wichtig
dass ihr jetzt nicht so viele nebenkleckert
weil da ist jetzt der Gramm genau abgewogen
so den Rest hole ich mir jetzt gleich einen
Teigschaber noch raus ich kann ja schon mal
für euch weitermachen und da kommt jetzt noch
das Eigelb mit rein das hat sich jetzt hier so
ein bisschen verfangen das eine Eigelb ist
ein bisschen zerlaufen aber es nehme ich
mir einfach raus es kommt hier mit rein macht
was mit der Konsistenz und ihr bekommt diese
typische vanillepuddingfarbe das verrühren wir
hier einfach vorab Klümpchen frei und ihr könnt
jetzt hier zum Topf schon mal Vanilleextrakt
geben ich weiß es ja Vanillepudding also da
nicht geizen wobei das schon sehr hoch
konzentriert ist so Vanilleextrakt ist
drin und Zucker für die Süße und dann wird es
einfach nur erwärmt ihr merkt es auch wenn er
so ganz kleine Bläschen sind es wird dann schön
warm und dann gibt ihr einfach hier unser Gemisch
mit dazu das müsstet ihr kurz vorher auch noch
mal verrühren weil in den 12 Minuten wo die
Milch erwärmt wird wird es ja auch noch mal also
die Stärke setzt sich dann auch schon wieder auf
dem Boden ab daher kurz vorher am besten auch
noch mal rühren und damit dazugeben [Musik]
den Pudding dann unter ständigem Rühren einmal
aufkochen lassen dann merkt ihr auch schon wie
schnell der ein liegt ich habe das jetzt
hier schon direkt umgefüllt und direkt an
der Oberfläche mit Frischhaltefolie abdecken
damit wir keine Haut haben es soll ja Menschen
geben die mögen puddinghaut was wir bis heute
ein Rätsel ist aber es brauchen wir in diesem
Fall wirklich nicht so das lasse ich jetzt auch
kurz abkühlen dann warten auf den Hefeteig und
dann geht's weiter so die Ruhezeit ist vorbei
der Hefeteig wird jetzt in acht gleichmäßig
große Teiglinge geteilt oh das ist richtig fluffig
der Teig und ich mache das jetzt einfach ja nach
Gefühl ich kann jetzt auch eine Waage nehmen und
das alles gleichmäßig viel wiegt aber ich finde
das geht jetzt auch ganz gut mit der Teigkarte
hier einfach in der Mitte dann noch mal jeweils
in der Mitte und dann noch mal in der Mitte und
dann haben wir acht Teiglinge der Rest ist jetzt
sehr sehr easy wir werden die Teiglinge hier
jetzt zu Kugeln formen also ich nehme mir dann
immer mit dem Teil von außen und ziehen so in die
Mitte bis ich eine eine Form habe und dann mache
ich entweder in den Handinnenflächen das ganze
noch mal Kugel rund oder ihr legt das mit der
unschönen Seite nach unten auf die Arbeitsfläche
und dann könnt ihr das in der Hand im Handballen
quasi so ein bisschen hin und her rollen und dann
habt ihr quasi eine wunderschöne Kugel die geben
jetzt direkt auf unser Backblech und dort darf das
dann auch noch mal 10 Minuten entspannen das war's
[Musik] so nach 10 Minuten Entspannung unterm
Tuch ganz ganz wichtig sonst trocknen sie
nämlich aus können wir schon weitermachen
und zwar mache ich jetzt so dass einfach
mit den Fingern noch mal erstmal flach
andrücken und dann nehme ich mir ein Glas
also irgendwas rundes was ihr da habt und
dann geht ihr dann noch mal richtig rein
ruhig mit ein bisschen Druck wenn ihr merkt
dass der Teig sich wieder zusammenzieht hat
er sich noch nicht genug entspannt dann könnt ihr
einfach noch mal mit dem Tuch abdecken lassen aber
so passt es jetzt bei mir und da kommt gleich
regelmäßig gleichmäßig unser Pudding rein und
den Ofen nämlich auch schon vorgeheizt auf 170
Grad Umluft weil ich möchte gerne zwei Bleche
gleichzeitig backen sonst könnt ihr auch 180 Grad
Ober und Unterhitze nehmen dadurch dass wir jetzt
auch bei Umluft Backen Leute es ist umso wichtiger
dass ihr das Hefegebäck mit dem Eigelb bestreicht
weil sonst wird es total trocken weil Umluft der
lässt ja noch mal das Blätter noch mal Luft in den
Ofen und ich möchte ja nicht dass das trocken mit
dem Gegenteil das soll ja schön fluffig schminken
und äh da wirkt ja einfach entgegen und außerdem
macht es halt noch mal wirklich eine schöne Bräune
[Musik]
so bei mir haben die Plunderteilchen jetzt 18
bzw 19 Minuten gebraucht also schaut nach 18
Minuten mal ob sie braun genug sind sie sollten
nicht zu dunkel werden und jetzt sind die bei
mir abgekühlt bzw ganz ganz leicht minimal war
noch und ich gebe jetzt Puderzucker oben drauf
und dann ist das Rezept auch schon fertig ich
muss sagen das ging echt schnell das staunt mich
gerade ein bisschen ich habe das nämlich lange
nicht mehr gemacht und doch ja ich brauche jetzt
eine Weile aber das ging echt klar so dann
sehen wir uns gleich zum Test wieder [Musik]
genug ich habe die puddingteilchen ich
habe einen Cappuccino hier ist sogar
noch so ein halbherziges Herz drauf
also ich habe es nicht verlernt und
jetzt gönne ich mich ich weiß
einfach direkt rein für euch
lecker kannst du mal ran weil man sieht so richtig
die Poren diese Poren ist ein Traum und genauso
wie es aussieht schmeckt es auch also so richtig
von außen ganz dünn und ganz leicht diese Kruste
aber im positiven Sinne es schmeckt super gut
dann beißt ihr euch in diesem warmen Hefeteig
also hier ist bei mir noch lauwarm und der ist
ultra fluffig die schmecken auch kalt aber ich
gebe euch einen Tipp ihr könnt sie auch am
nächsten Tag z.B ein paar Sekunden in der
Mikrowelle erwärmen und eigentlich muss ich mich
jetzt noch durch diesen Pudding Kern beißen auch
das mache ich jetzt auch noch ich es euch jetzt
ein Vorbild könnte das auch sofort machen [Musik]
Leute macht's nach ich bin der glücklichste
Mensch der Welt ein Cappuccino dabei und
verabschiede mich jetzt von euch und
sage bis zum nächsten mal auf meinem
Kanal lasst ein Abo da Leute wenn ihr sie
schon längst gemacht habt das war bald mal
die 700.000 klein ich habe das Gefühl ich
habe überall Puderzucker auf jeden Fall
wünsche ich euch viel Spaß beim Nachmachen
und sage Tschüss bis zum nächsten Mal [Musik]